hey ben howdy uh so i've been following
you since
uh your peers morgan interview years
back that was awesome
uh question so i hear you put a lot of
emphasis on the free market
fixing for example like racism and being
self-regulatory
a pure example of this is if a business
refuses business to a minority
a competing business will pop up and
steal the business of folks who found
the former business immoral
and that will run the racist business
out of business
you're following me here all right all
right so with the country so large is
the united states couldn't there
still be enough niche market to keep the
original business afloat
if there is enough of a niche market to
keep it afloat does the government have
the responsibility to make it illegal to
refuse
service based on the code of someone's
skin or do you see that as
government overreach setting bad
precedence so i think that there's
certainly
niche markets for racism i mean there's
still people who sell racist crap online
and do just fine with it
but the question is are these people who
are going to thrive and also
are we willing to sacrifice your right
to freedom of association in order to
crack down
on a few bad actors and this is always
the question when it comes to rights
it's the same question with gun rights
are we willing to crack down on hundreds
of millions of uh 100 million gun owners
in the united states
in order to get the few bad actors are
you willing to crack down on freedom of
association for hundreds of millions of
people
in order that we get a few bad actors
particularly when the market prevents
these people from becoming wildly
successful
they are punished by the market because
if you're a racist you can only cater to
that niche as opposed to
being able to cater to a broader
possible audience the best example
of of integration by the way through the
free market uh
is woolworth's the the woolworths
counter which was boycotted in 1960
before the civil rights act by a bunch
of black students who walked in and they
said that they wanted
to be served and the restaurant said
well by local law we cannot serve you
and they said well we're just going to
sit here until you do
and pretty soon the entire world will
change changed its segregation policy
and that's because they're a bunch of
people who said we're not going to shop
there anymore right the montgomery bus
boycott is another example of this sort
of stuff working
i think that that is is effective i
think it's actually more effective now
than it was then because then
you're at least bound by location right
what if there was no competing business
that could find a place to rent across
the street now everything's online
so you can get anything online now all
these people who are walking into
christian bakers and demanding that they
serve their same-sex wedding first of
all if you can't find a gay baker in the
united states i don't know where you
live
but second of all
but second of all there are lots of cake
making companies that you can go online
and just buy a cake from them
and if that christian is willing to lose
the business well then the christian's
willing to lose the business it seems to
me that's a much better cure
for the problem of supposed
discrimination than
saying that we are going as a government
to regulate who you can and cannot
serve as uh as a client uh as i pointed
i point this out to jimmy kimmel who is
doing this one of my favorite punching
bags
uh jimmy kimmel was was saying this
about exactly this case with the gay
bakers and i said well jimmy
i would like for you to write me a
comedy routine about the nastiness and
horrors of hillary clinton barack obama
and i demand you do so right now
right this is your skill set how dare
you deny me service just because i'm a
conservative you're going to deny me
service that's discrimination
how could you do such a thing the same
principle that allows jimmy kimmel to
refuse me service
allows the the christian couple to
refuse to serve the same-sex
wedding um and i'm i'm pretty extreme
when it comes to
you know the freedom of association i
think that you should be able to reject
anybody from your business you want to
even if you're a piece of crap and you
reject people you really shouldn't
are you going to push for debate oh i'm
happy to debate jimmy kimmel anytime
anywhere
can you wake me up in the middle of the
night let's do it